we've got a voicemail that number is two
one nine to david p here's a voicemail
that came in over the weekend let's take
a listen to it oh i david my name is
antonio I'm one of your listeners and
members in Toronto Ontario Canada I was
listening to your show and you mentioned
that you thought that Boston's bylaw
requiring the planting of I think five
trees for every tree you cut down in
development didn't do much because the
new trees would be saplings and would
not do the same work as a grown tree
would what is actually fifty percent
carbon and once a tree is fully grown
its ability to remove carbon from the
atmosphere is actually diminished so
cutting and replacing tree as long as
you don't burn down the old tree or let
it rot so that the carbon is not
released back into the atmosphere is
actually a carbon sinks or capturing
carbon by doing that that's why when you
build with wood as long as you source it
responsibly is actually environmentally
friendly so because you're in a nutshell
just taking that carbon from the
atmosphere and storing it to your
building anyways
lock the show keep up the good work
Cheers thank you
a very informed voicemail yeah so I on
the bonus show we talked about a rule
that I believe exists in Boston which is
that if you cut down trees for
constructing new homes you have to
replant them I believe on a five to one
ratio five new trees for every one tree
and I was as a non-scientist under the
impression that little trees do not
remove as much carbon from the
atmosphere as do big trees but what this
caller is saying is that actually it's
the growth of a tree from a sapling to a
large tree that actually produces the
most carbon sequestration because trees
are 50% carbon so assuming that that's
true and it sounded very well-reasoned I
stand corrected and hey we all learned
something and for that I can't thank you
enough
on the bonus show today Donald Trump is
going to be releasing more documents
related to the Kennedy assassination of
1963 and I think you're gonna be very
interested in this I have two stories
from the conference I was at in Las
Vegas to tell on the bonus show today
one relating to David Blaine and one
relating to possible airline I guess
safety issues that I observed although
it's not a mechanical safety issue per
se anyway I think you're going to like
today's bonus show and I incur
you to sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership coupon code is I voted 17 if
you want it you can also get access to
the bonus show instantly by becoming a
five dollar patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show we'll speak to you
then